[Music]
- one action
off the record welcome back to off the
record or we talked about whatever well
that was the fastest you've ever said
the off the record is really it's time
until we all jump in and then interrupt
therefore everything about what everyone
Wow
busta rhymes like you really found out
through vanessa this is just my
observation when you have a bunch of
loud ass people together and all of her
family members are loud as [ __ ] every
single one of those [ __ ] speak
hella fast hmm I can't understand them
because we talk relatively fast to these
I was her sister was trying to explain
something to me I started laughing in
her face she's like what what do you all
about we laughing about
I don't know what Julie just started
dying laugh and she goes what's the
problem I don't know what the [ __ ]
you're saying were they from like what
are they they're just Vietnamese but
they're just from here but they just
have a big family so everybody has to
get their awarded edgewise
but they're just fighting each other all
the time so they don't know how to speak
at a normal pace god I only know that
feeling when we're just ragging on each
other mmm cuz it's like that the like
it's funny and you want to ride the wave
so then it's like you wanna ride yeah
yeah yeah I did that with my brothers
and sister that's the only time yeah
yeah you guys know and I'm trying to
talk and I can't get though my thing out
and I'm just like panicking my brain is
like you're stuck and I give up that
happens to you all hmm weird
it's off good guys want to hear
something [ __ ] crazy though so Tim
and I we were in wait did you want to
[ __ ] answer huh what no you guys
another point so it's called off the
record you don't have a choice
so do it we were in Iowa right and dude
we were at this [ __ ] ball Oh God and
my god you want to talk about the worst
fan situation ever but not for me cuz
nobody knows me but for him dude what
was he like Native American or some yeah
it was it was it was a it wasn't
annoying
I mean look okay it was a group it was a
drunk as group also it was a really
super hole-in-the-wall bar you know I'm
saying so I felt like it was all like
did I already know you won one so I came
in and won
specifically she was kind of eyeing me I
saw them kind of like in my purse just
kind of looking and talking how did you
guys even know to go to that bar we went
to the bar because we were on hold for a
Peruvian restaurant our name was on the
list and we walked it a superbomb
Peruvian so Bob Lomo saltado semi diet
oh no in Des Moines Iowa
[ __ ] authentic gasps Peruvian food
was fire crazy so we go to this bar down
the street while we're waiting and then
this fan recognizes me she wants to
she's like her friends like hey oh my
god she's such a fan cuz she picked him
like sure so like I take a picture I
give her a hug and then right after that
okay and there was like a really cool
like older black dude who was I saw him
at I don't know we wore on my mom's fine
but see it was kind of loud I didn't
know that that big dude was cool with
him I just saw to take him aside yeah so
I took off my gloves know what hi Jenica
cuz it was [ __ ] 1582 15 degrees it
was negative 15 degrees I was doing
surgery gloves like he's all fancy
[ __ ] Cruella de Vil I took off my
gloves you know what with a zipper on it
gotta fold that [ __ ] six times oh so
long
so I'm chillin I know so then um this
like super drunk like I think he was
Native America like cuz they're like
long hair and like you know you just you
know I think he was an American dude cuz
we're racist it comes up to me and he's
like he's drunk and he's like man you
could even say in words that you know
you're a little you're a little I'm like
cool I'm thinking he's a fan right so my
cool head Coco yeah that's when I think
that's one and this other than the older
black dude and their other friend they
came out to me and the older black tee
was like eh sorry about him and he's
really drunk and he saw you like you
know taking a picture with his
girlfriend I think he got a little
jealous or whatever right I was like oh
so and then later on the whole group
comes up to me they want a picture they
want a good picture
so getting the taste you I'm like
smiling whatever and then um and then
big dude with the long hair he's behind
me so I'm like smiling also I feel I
feel someone grab my like do this
literally in the kitchen like this and
then and so I kind of move and then I'm
like whatever let's take this picture
that I take another one whatever you
graduate again no no he ain't grabbing
but I go off to the side and we kind of
um and then I think and then that's when
black dude really pulled me aside and
this is I think this is when you took
your gloves off and he pulls me aside
these somethings that a man look I'm
sorry about him bla bla oh god guess but
it's off to the corner so David and the
producer girl that was with us they're
kind of watching making sure I'm okay
but I was I was good
so then black dude because it's talking
to us everything's fine the drunk cool
is just being in the drunk area and
their hand in my peripherals I [ __ ]
see you want to tell this part oh yeah
so we're sitting here off to the side
and off to the back and then you hear it
like some kind of commotion in the back
that big Native American dude is upset
because he took a picture with Tim and
he grabs his girl's face and smushed in
them Chuck's yeah yeah just like this
and you know in those situations
everybody says [ __ ] yo if I ever see a
guy put his hands on a grommet do
something you know what we did we said
well it would've been different if you
like if you like punch there and and
okay look their friends were grabbing
yeah because as soon as he did it like a
homegirl here's a Julia what are you
doing blah blah blah and then like
little hide like here and here we're
doing what are you doing stop so that
dude grabbed his girl's face bush yeah
basketball grab like this yeah and
immediately the [ __ ] is like in the
movies cuz the [ __ ] music stopped
yeah skirt yeah yeah the party's over
man and the bartender is pouring the
drink stone is coming out yes over the
company so we're over there like [ __ ]
Dave is taking off his gloves [ __ ]
took out my powder I went like that with
whenever I'm so looking for me I'm
little so whenever I'm thinking of
fights about to go down I'm looking like
what school can I pick up to [ __ ] hit
somebody with he don't say what's the
night in there I thought you were gonna
say what stool can I jump on top
no when a fights about the habit I
immediately look for weapons
I'm little so I look for where I can
[ __ ] curl into a corner it was such a
weird situation because like godly open
you have an option to run away as fast
as possible but we were in the bar
towards the back where it was closed off
and they were in front of the entrance
yeah so like for me I don't like
fighting but it's it we're in a place
where we don't know where we're at and
the first thing I thought was like oh
this guy should want to start some [ __ ]
yeah I know in my head I was like let's
see if he's out its hardest [ __ ]
stand practicing he does comes in handy
but the only thing I was thinking about
was that was like just like you it's a
bar fight dude [ __ ] I did like I was
thinking okay well one of these are
coming I'm like thinking like okay
there's the chairs here just get your
back to a [ __ ] wall because you know
just in case and then let's grab some
glass grab a bottle or something you're
chucking it cuz like what are we
supposed to do and there were big
[ __ ] guys to buy them yes they're all
my size so I'm like don't be like being
like fat [ __ ] you're like they're like
the electrician construction burly men
you're burly ass men and if a guy can
smush a girl's face in public he don't
give a [ __ ] about my face so I'm like I
was legit kind of worried I was like
okay we do luckily I mean as the homies
were de-escalating with with big dude we
sat there for Luba and I was like yo
let's just get out of here Peruvians go
get the Peruvian food which ones by year
in good dude
so it made me want to be like I'm
looking up all the Peruvian spots in LA
and I'm eating proven feed regularly
eating the peruvian fruit through the
window where you see in the girl getting
her ass beat just across the parking lot
so everybody fly through a window it was
the girl you imagine me with such an
insecure person that gets upset at like
he was blasted drunk dude and now as I
did could you be a stereotype even more
[Laughter]
[ __ ] honey box over here just [ __ ]
busted girl people yeah that God was mad
aggressive man how did the girl react
was she like she was gonna like laugh it
off she was like usually laughing off
like she was used to it yeah everybody
was mad drunk she was [ __ ] pissed
drunk too like I think she was more
embarrassed anything so she they're
probably slapping each other yeah but
that guy he came out cuz I had the
chapter two and three and that's like
the LA area code and that's how he came
over and the other side are you from LA
the black dude oh and then started
chopping it up his stuff he was super
cool the mediator black guy yeah super
nice man oh that situation though and it
was cold they get a 15 degree wind chill
dude it was [ __ ] freezing man
fighting in the coldest sucks cuz you
have you have cold fingers yeah I can
imagine people live out there dude
housing prices are probably good as [ __ ]
yeah what brought them over there
especially the Peruvian guy that said
let me leave this hot-ass place to this
cold-ass place and [ __ ] cook up some
Lomo saltado Joe in the middle of the
winter because we were at a bacon
festival mmm it was just all bacon
oh that sounds good that's what a bacon
okay it was it was good it was my scream
and but it was also like it was like a
lot of salt you know since this was like
a lot of bacon like some sausage bacon
wrapped sausage bacon wraps like
everything bacon they weren't as
creative as I thought they would be
right so you know like if you have like
a festival of some sort I feel like you
know like people will repurpose that and
do some crazy with it
bacon doughnut like it's cream bacon
yeah we take a sausage and they would
wrap bacon over here they would take
bacon and put it on a pizza
yeah what we expected bacon bits on a
salad how can you hate bacon though
right we literally in the middle of it
we had an hour break we fell asleep on a
bench cuz we had the itis yeah [ __ ]
meat sweats man all but speaking of
innovative one one little you missed it
one table with a did bacon and eggs dude
oh yeah that was weird bacon and eggs
is that normal that's just right okay
yeah yeah this being all day yeah that's
a that's a delicious breakfast just
making jokes making jokes
I like smoked bacon peppered bacon
turkey bit I like all kinds of baked
that was turkey bacon that was pretty
bomb over Turkey and that was mad
aggressive too by the way mr. turkey
bacon man because I denied in three
times and he kept grabbing my arm he was
like yo take this Peters picture over
here with this turkey bacon stuff and
I'm like hey we're good man and he just
somehow wants to be viral really bad oh
I feel like he's just frustrated because
he's turkey bacon man and I'm in a pig
bacon town Oh everyone's part like
turkey big or openly talking [ __ ] about
the turkey bacon spot too like I was
overhearing it they're like [ __ ]
break turkey bacon yeah that's why he's
mad you know they say turkey bacon is
like condom sex it's just like it smells
good I like Turkey baked more than pork
baby more than raw sex I see this - yeah
it's like Bologna and [ __ ] real
prosciutto or whatever you know yeah I
guess that's true Bologna something else
don't a fried bologna Bell mmm so good
it's cancer-causing but it's delicious
take a slice of Bologna that is stored
in the frying pan frying pan
you've never been getting in your life
have you my babysitter and guard do you
know use the woman yeah she put me on
fry Bologna is such a ghetto thing to do
though oh I don't like Bologna you take
fried bologna and then you get that
[ __ ] Wonder Bread [ __ ] boy no mayo
mmm dude dude that was a weird kid we
call that like kid gold no weird kid my
mom would buy that and everyone in the
house ate that but then my loser ass
only wanted wheat bread and ham did you
also eat raisin bread as it look kid I
eat an alle dude where did you get the
wheat bread with the Roman guy yeah yeah
my family always got I was like why
can't we get the one I love because it
was sweet was it sweet it was - yeah
rebo I should bomb me buzz bombs call
this pronounce bean ball beam be IMU
no it's beam beam bow is it like is it
is it ethnic it's the Mexican bread it's
the mole with the bear they have a lot
it's like their hostess company the
people beer bread people with bread
bimbo I thought it was bimbo that's cuz
you are sexist and you're trash well
your was tight I was like a Twitter meme
right there you're sexist and you're
trash that's every tweet bimbo so did
you guys think of the Reid how did you
guys announce that we had a read oh no I
did vlog about it but someone wasn't
there and broke my heart I was hoping
someone was gonna be there to help read
and give us know to see if you like the
movie but I guess not a true friend I
told you to just send me the [ __ ]
scripts oh what a coincidence that he's
here oh it would have been really
helpful if a friend that got his film
into Sundance that actually has some X
how many times I say send me the script
so I can read it no like oh I can't go
to the read high well because we're all
doing sin I was there you were there but
I have said foods and right now I'm
dealing with selling a business right
now oh yeah no because we find you're so
busy he's on TV any still no he's not
any not anymore ones don't sent foods
and thanks for knowing good friend am I
trying to blow you what bro why you did
pull him up in a bad way [ __ ] why did
you leave wild and out huh did you get
kicked out or did you decide to leave um
it was one of those things where we they
kick me off yeah so who's gonna replace
you as the Asian what no well here's the
thing I I did it I put it I put Daniel
Fung I did I didn't like I put it I put
it to people like this where you know
when you're in a relationship and you
want to break up with somebody really
cute or not and like I'm trying to tell
you I'm not Tiffany I told you like what
you want to break up with somebody but
then you're like oh it's cool they
didn't do nothing crazy yet I'm a chill
and then
and then one day they're like hey maybe
we should break up and you're like yeah
I was feeling the same way so that's
what happened how many seasons really I
was on eight seasons oh that's on six
years
yeah it just registered in my head
because every time I get ignored on
public when I'm with him I realize he's
been on TV for eight years six years he
just said stupid hey you don't even know
he was off it alright so shut your mouth
you understand you pretty [ __ ] [ __ ] you
David pretty okay yes on a shitbucket
rise up like a bouquet me up pretty
[ __ ] wait yeah I'll a simple [ __ ] but
you're pretty that's pretty simple [ __ ]
but they told me it was because they
were just what they've been putting on
so many new people you know I'm saying
like a lot of new like a lot of like IG
famous people and [ __ ] no talent that's
what Carlos would say with names that
don't even make sense
like they'll be like Izzy the fizz or
something everyone's names Daniel a
thing of the Dean who the [ __ ] are these
fools easy the face is gonna fire
everyone's name is like something the
print prints the wiki they said they
were prints the wiki it's kinda like
moving in a different direction and um
and and I think they could tell I was
kind of like tuned out for a lot of it
as well so um you know whose time I was
definitely feeling like I wasn't wiling
out group chat with the boys every
season like yo alright this is my last
season guys they're my last season
they're like y'all shut up oh and they
were right cuz I kept coming back but
then finally they let me go I was like
alright cool
I remember when you tweeted out to Nick
Cannon tryin to get on well enough you
remember that you're that guy that guy
got the biggest bags under his eyes ever
dude he's tired poor man he works so
hard but that's why he has the biggest
bags in his [ __ ] bank account you
guys stop doing them stupid baby braids
though he looks dumb shout-out to you
Nick Cannon there's one episode of while
analysis if you me talk about his hair
where we're like you know you have to
get behind the person and like make them
laugh or whatever so Nick had his hair
out it's just in like like a [ __ ]
lowlife you know this is curly and
right and then so DC gets up behind them
and he goes hey Nick that's your that's
so funny like that guy's name DC young
flowers easy and flies that mean man
is it Affairs man like a [ __ ] 80s
[ __ ] b-boy dude all those [ __ ]
dancers man never introduced their real
name is so [ __ ] annoying I'm like hey
I'm David I'm busy the fist no what's
your [ __ ] name you're 40 years old
you're not fast now okay
yo okay speaking of old ass dancers
quick rocket ship what's up me and Rick
we're at the food court in the Lakewood
mall and there was this like older buff
black dude right who comes up to us he
has his little daughter and he's talking
about he's like yo y'all coming to the
mall a lot yeah I remember you know 20
years ago man I used to be in this same
spot I mean Rick looking like this mall
wasn't around 20 years ago so he's
talking about but the whole time he's
talking to us right
he's pop loging did you meet Bob and Ray
bopping Andre out while all this sound
familiar
yeah I mean he's this guy was kind of
buff okay okay so it's all black guy
he's talking to us and he's like yeah
you know I just be my friends back in
hey you know it's crazy just doing the
same [ __ ] every one little dot is like
[ __ ] Tavener at legacies all right
calm down calm down
yes y'all got you still got it like you
probably why did you guys go oh exactly
that cuz the same moves that work back
then they don't work today man he's all
like what's up what's up
[Laughter]
[Music]